- [Voiceover] Now that we've
spent a couple of videos
exploring a scenario where I'm
taking multiple free throws
and figuring out the
probability of making K
of the scores and six
attempts or in N attempts.
Let's actually define a random variable
using this scenario and see if we can
construct it's probability distribution
and we'll actually see that
it's a binomial distribution.
So, let's define the random variable X.
So, let's say that X
is equal to the number,
the number of made shots,
number of made free throws
when taking,
when taking six free throws.
So, it's how many of the six do you make?
And we're going to assume what we assumed
in the first video in this series of this,
these making free throws.
So, we're gonna assume the seventy percent
free throw probability right over here.
So, assuming assumptions,
assuming seventy percent free throw,
free throw percentage.
All right.
So, let's figure out the probabilities
of the different values that
X could actually take on.
So, let's see, what is the probability,
what is the probability
that X is equal to zero?
That even though you have a
seventy percent free throw percentage
that you make none of the shots
and actually you could
calculate this through
probably some common
sense without using all
of these fancy things but just
to make things consistent,
I'm gonna write it out.
So, this is going to
be, this is going to be,
it's going to be equal to six choose zero
times zero point seven to the zeroth power
times zero point three to the sixth power,
and this right over here
is gonna end up being one.
This over here's going
to end up being one.
And so, you're just gonna be
left with zero point three
to the sixth power and I
calculated it ahead of time.
So, if we round to the nearest,
if we do, if we round our
percentages to the nearest tenth,
this is going to give you approximately,
approximately, well, if we round
the decimal to the nearest,
to the nearest thousandth you're gonna
get something like that
which is approximately
equal to zero point one percent chance
of you missing all of them.
So, roughly I'm speaking, roughly here
a one in a thousand,
one in a thousand chance
of that happening, of
missing all six free throws.
Now, let's keep going, this is fun.
So, what is the probability that our
random variable is equal to 1?
Well, this is going to be six choose one
times zero point seven to the first power
times zero point three to
the six minus first power.
So, it's a fifth power.
And I calculated this and this is
approximately zero point zero one
or we could say one percent.
So, it's still a fairly low probability.
Ten times more likely than this roughly
but still a fairly low probability.
Let's keep going.
So, the probability
that x is equal to two,
well, that's what our first
video was essentially.
So, this is going to be six choose two
times zero point seven squared times zero,
zero point three to the fourth power,
and we saw that this is
approximately going to be
zero, zero point zero six,
or we could say six percent,
and obviously you could type
these things in a calculator
and get a much more precise answer
but just for the sake
of just getting a sense
of what these probabilities all look like,
that's why I'm giving
these rough estimates.
Kind of, I guess you
could say, to the closest,
maybe, tenth of a, tenth of a percent.
And actually and if you
round to the closest tenth
of a percent you actually actually get
to six point oh percent
and this is one point,
one point oh percent 'cause
this we actually went
to a tenth of a percent
here but let's keep going.
We're obviously going to have
to do a few more of these.
So, let me just make sure
I have enough real estate.
All right, so, the probability
that our random variable is equal to three
is going to be six choosethree
and I'm sure you could probably
fill this out on your own
but I'm going to do it.
Zero point seven to the third power
times zero point three
to the six minus three
which is a third power which
is approximately equal to,
well, it's going to be
zero point one eight five
or eighteen point five,
eighteen point five percent.
So, yeah, that's definitely
within the realm of possibility.
I mean, all of these are
in the realm of possibility
but it's starting to be a
non-insignificant probability.
So, now, let's do the probability
that our random variable is equal to four.
Well, it's going to be six choose four
times zero point seven to the fourth power
times zero point three
to the six minus four
or second power which is equal to,
this is going to get equal to
or approximately, 'cause
I am, I am taking away
a little bit of the precision when
I write these things down.
Zero point three two four.
So, approximately thirty two
point four percent chance
of making exactly four out
of the six free throws.
All right, two more to go.
Let's see, I have not used purple as yet.
So, the probability that a
random variable is equal to five
it's gonna be six choose five or zero,
at times I should say, zero
point seven to the fifth power
times zero point three to the first power
and that is going to be roughly,
roughly zero point three zero three
which is thirty point three percent.
That's interesting, one more left.
So, the probability
that I make all of them,
of all six, is going to be equal to,
is equal to six choose six
and zero point seven to the sixth power
times zero point three to the zeroth power
which is, this right over
here is going to be one,
this is going to be one, so it's really
just zero point seven to the
sixth, to the sixth power
and this is approximately
zero point one one eight.
I calculated that ahead of time,
which is eleven point eight.
Eleven point eight percent.
And so, there's something
interesting that's going on here.
The first time we looked
binomial distribution
we said, "Hey, there's
a symmetry as we kind of
"got to some type of a peak and went down,
"but I don't see that symmetry here."
And the reason you're not
seeing that symmetry is
that you are more likely to
make a free throw than not.
It was you have a seventy
percent free throw probability.
This is no longer just
flipping a fair coin.
Where you will see the symmetry
is in these coefficients.
If you calculate these coefficients,
six choose zero is one.
Six choose six is one.
You would see that six choose one is six
and six choose five is six.
You'd see six choose two is fifteen
and six choose four is also fifteen,
and then six choose three is twenty.
So, you definitely see, you definitely see
the symmetry in the coefficients
but then these things are weighted
by the fact that you're more likely
to make something than miss something.
If these were both point five
then you would also see the
symmetry right over here.
And you can plot this
to essentially visualize
what the probability distribution
looks like for this example
and I encourage you to do that.
To take these different cases,
just like we did in that first example
with the fair coin, and plot these.
But this essentially does give you
the probability distribution for,
for the random variable in question.
This is, I just wrote it out
instead of just visualizing it
but it says, "Okay, well, what's the...
"These are the different values
"that this random variable can take on."
It can't, it can't take on negative one
or it can't be fifteen point
five or pi or one million.
These are the only seven values
that this random variable
can take on and I've just
given you the probabilities,
or I guess you could say
the rough probabilities
of the random variable taking on
each of those, each of those seven values.